Ya hemos visto que una función "f",
mapea elementos del dominio...
dominio...
¡De lujo! es decir,
si te tomas un elemento de su dominio la función,
lo mapea a un elemento de su codominio...
a un elemento del codominio,
¡de lujo!
codominio...
Así que si por ejemplo, nosotros tomamos por aquí
el conjunto del dominio,
y bueno déjame hacerlo con color anaranjado...
por aquí me voy a tomar a...
el dominio de esta función
y bueno, vamos a tomar algunos elementos
de manera aleatoria por aquí.
Imagínate que este es el 1,
ok, por acá tengo al -1.
ok, por acá imagínate que me tomo al 7,
y por acá,
por acá se me antoja tomarme a pi.
Ok, ahora, todos estos son miembros del dominio de "f",
ahora imagínate que tenemos por acá el condominio,
y déjame hacerlo con este color...
por acá tenemos el codominio
y ahora digamos que "f" mapea al 1,
o dicho de otra manera, "f" de 1,
"f" de 1 lo manda para acá
y toma el valor de -3
va a tomar aquí el valor de -3.
Es decir que "f" de 1 es igual a -3
o "f" mapea al 1 al valor de -3,
ahora imagínate también
que "f" mapea al número -1,
mapea al número -1 al valor de 7.
Ok, "f" de -1 es 7, vamos a suponer eso
y también vamos a suponer que "f"
mapea al 7, "f" de 7,
va a ser igual a 10 ¿ok?
supongamos que es igual a 10
y por último vamos a decir que "f" de pi...
que "f" de pi, también toma el valor de 10...
también toma el valor de 10.
Así que aquí tenemos el mapeo de la función
y lo primero que quiero que te des cuenta,
es que es una función legítima,
porque recuerda,
que para que tengamos una función,
para cada una de las entradas,
se tiene que mapear a una única salida,
a sólo una salida.
Esto no sería una función si pasara algo como esto,
si "f"...
bueno, nosotros sabemos que "f" de pi,
de "f" de pi, es lo mismo que 10
y esto lo hace una función,
¡ojo! porque estamos mapeando
a pi al 10.
Para la entrada pi, sabemos que vamos a obtener
una única salida que es 10,
pero si estuviéramos haciendo aquí un tipo de relación,
que no fuera función,
y déjame quitar esto de aquí,
pasaría algo así, pues si ponemos a pi,
algunas veces me va a dar 10,
pero tal vez otras veces me dé, el valor de 11,
y en este momento ya no es una función.
Esto no va a ser una función,
porque estamos mapeando a pi,
primero al valor de 10
y después al valor de 11,
y esto no es correcto,
si queremos pensar en una función.
Recuerda para cada entrada,
le vamos a mapear solamente una salida,
¡una sola!
Ojo, podemos tener como en este caso,
dos entradas que se mapeen a una misma salida,
pero nosotros sabemos, en este caso que "f" de 7,
es lo mismo que 10,
y también sabemos que "f" de pi,
también toma el valor de 10.
Ahora lo que quiero ver en este vídeo es,
cuándo una función no es invertible.
Ya hemos visto que la inversa de una función,
es un mapeo entre un elemento del codominio
con su respectivo elemento del dominio,
así que la inversa,
debe mapear al -3 al 1,
la inversa de "f", ok,
"f" inversa debe mapear al -3,
al valor de 1.
Y esto es porque...
y déjame ponerlo así,
porque sabemos que "f" de 1...
"f" de 1,
esto es exactamente igual a -3
y por lo tanto, "f" inversa
y déjame ponerlo cuando este color...
"f" inversa de -3 ,y ojo,
"f" inversa,
también debe de ser una función,
y por lo tanto debe cumplir,
las mismas propiedades que una función,
por lo tanto debe mapear al -3...
¡Ah! solamente una cosa, en este caso
"f" inversa de -3 es 1...
"f" inversa de -3 es 1.
Y bueno, aquí ya tenemos una idea
de qué va a pasar con el 7,
"f" inversa de 7,
va a ser igual a -1,
recuerda que esta es "f" inversa...
"f" inversa...
"f" inversa de 7, va a ser igual a -1,
y eso tiene mucho sentido,
porque nosotros sabíamos,
que "f" de -1,
esto era igual a 7,
y ahora podemos escribir que "f" inversa,
que f inversa de 7,
ok, esto me va a llevar al valor de -1.
Ok, pero ahora algo muy interesante
pasa justo aquí,
¿cuál debería de ser el valor que tomaría,
"f" inversa de 10?
Si yo trato de mapear al 10,
existen dos elementos del dominio,
que cuando yo aplico la función,
me van a dar a 10 en el codominio,
por lo tanto, la pregunta sería,
¿quién sería la función inversa de 10?
ahora,
si tú tratas de ver qué "f" es invertible,
entonces la función inversa debería mapear,
a este elemento...
a solo un elemento del dominio
pero en este caso lo mapea
a dos elementos del dominio.
Así que, "f" inversa de 10,
esto es igual a 7,
o esto es igual a pi.
Es justo lo raro que tenemos aquí
y en este caso como la función inversa no puede hacer,
que los elementos del codominio
se mapeen únicamente a una cosa,
entonces decimos que
esta función no es invertible.
Y déjame ponerlo aquí,
esta función, no es invertible...
y déjame ponerlo aquí,
invertible.
Y bueno, esto pasa porque el mapeo inverso,
del codominio al dominio,
la relación inversa, no es una función,
pues no podemos tomarnos a cualquier elemento,
de nuestro codominio,
y que se mapee,
a un único elemento de nuestro dominio.
Pues el 10,
no sabemos si se va a mapear a pi,
o se va a mapear a 7.
así que esta función "f",
que recuerda que es una función,
porque cada uno
de sus elementos del dominio,
está bien definido a un único elemento
de su codominio.
Pero el camino de regreso no es cierto,
para la función inversa,
a cada elemento de este codominio, de este conjunto,
no va a solo un elemento
de este otro conjunto,
pues el 10 se puede mapear a 7 o a pi.
Así que otra forma de verlo sería la siguiente,
"f" no es invertible.
No es una "f" invertible,
aunque "f" si sea función,
pero el mapeo inverso no es una función,
y por lo tanto "f" no es invertible.